it is 26 year old zack effluent on the
mound for the phillies tonight
last started on tuesday at boston
couldn't get past four innings allowed
four earned runs got a lot of runs of
support however
swanson's been hot he's hit safely in
eight in a row
swanson sends that one well hit into
left into the corner
where it bounces up and over the wall
for a ground rule doubly
and here's freddie to try to pick up a
run nobody out runner at second
3-2 and he loses freeman on ball four
there's travis darno now was used as a
pinch hitter yesterday after taking a
ball in the knee on friday night
first pitch is grounded up the middle
segura flips to gregorius and the
phillies get the double play
which should have been taylor made
wasn't freddie's wearing a microphone
for us again tonight
oh come on come here gene come here d.d
that wasn't scary enough for you
i wasn't yelling loud enough to scare
him
wichita state guy first rounder back in
2018.
sends a drive to deep center field and
that one's gone first
big league home run for the rookie alec
bowm
and it's the breaking ball waits on it
very nicely and it hits it a long ways
looking a little bit like jason wirth
can we send a guy in there to get that
first career homer ball
oh he's going to want that one back even
though it's wet
absolutely right it's a really nice
first home run
it's a good story too why is your ball
water logged well because i hit it 450
feet in dead center
really nice congratulations hoskins
singled in his first at bat tonight
hoskins sends the ball well he hit to
left that one's got a chance
and that one's gone two-run shot police
hoskins
measured and boom great swing
nice and tight balanced and behind the
baseball
and didi gregorius matter
with a ball well hit to right and that
one goes
sir fourth as a philly the breaking ball
in a great swing waited for it softball
time
freeman now with runners at second and
third and nobody out
two to freeman hit well into the
opposite corner
chasing mccutcheon who looks up and
plays it off a bounce
both runs score and it's a 4-2
phillies lead friedman getting the
sinker fading away
hitting it away head down in that
classic
beautiful swing well balanced and it
cuts the deficit in half
so now marcelo zuna i don't love
the infield halfway here i hope play the
infield back
3-2 pitch and ozuna lines it past
bowman to left field it brings it around
it's a one-run affair
and by playing the infield in there it
cost you an
out but it also costs you a run third
baseman
in no man's territory and what could
have been very easy play
became an impossible play boy that
happened in a hurry a single a hit
batsman
and then an error and now it's andrew
mccutchen with the bases loaded
lets it fly and lines it into left to
base hit that'll bring in bow
on to third goes knapp one in one on
and a 5-3 lead for the phillies it's
going to be up to jt real mucho now
who's hitler so far tonight
and real muso pops it up
houdini tucson gets out of a base is
loaded
nobody out jam with only one run
crossing the plate
5-3 philly here's a former national
league mvp bryce harper
rice is hitless so far tonight
celebrating what would have been the
42nd birthday
of the late kobe bryant by wearing a
kobe jersey underneath his
philly jersey kobe cleats and kobe
was born in philly
and it's not working out for harper
tonight just a little bit out of sync
tonight a little disconnected
for the big man harper tonight so now
travis garneau who has been quiet
tonight
batting with two out the base is empty
pops it up and harper can't make the
catch that's a fair ball
the throw into first is in time to get
him
in the pitcher embry with a terrific
backdoor pick right here
covering first base hoskins heads up and
derno probably should be standing at
second base because that ball was up in
the air for about 10 seconds
and embry loves it luke jackson is the
new reliever for atlanta
he'll face bryce harper
harper with a smash gobbled up by
camargo
well that's some of the loudest contact
of the night a little old-school defense
here
harper can't catch a break tonight an
absolute rocket
taking base hit great play takes his
time
and then a strike and the four-time
all-star represents the winning run at
the plate with two gone in the last of
the ninth
curveball lined into the gap in left
center field
[Applause]
one runs gonna score a player at the
plate on swansea
what a finish in atlanta we're going to
look at this again
to see if andrew knapp blocked the plate
we talked about didi gregorius
one of the best most accurate arm great
play
center fielder shortstop catcher
terrific and the call is upheld that's
it a 5-4 finish in atlanta